oui merci luc la question de l'adhésion
aux valeurs nationales est plus que
jamais posée face aux périls qui
menacent notre nation face à la guerre
qui lui a été déclaré et je crois que la
meilleure réponse dans ce combat dans
cette guerre que nous nous devons livrer
jusqu'à la victoire
c'est de rappeler la force la pertinence
la solidité des valeurs millénaires qui
ont fait la france et parmi ces valeurs
que vous évoquez légitimement il y a
aussi cette nécessité de cet équilibre
entre droits et devoirs la nation donne
beaucoup de droits mais chaque citoyen
doit se poser aussi la question et
devoirs envers son pays et le service
national qui ne pourra plus prendre la
même configuration qui l'ayant revêtez
lorsqu'il y avait le service militaire
la question du service national et pas
du service militaire doit se poser
personnellement et c'est le cadre du
débat aujourd'hui je suis favorable à ce
qu'il y ait un service national
obligatoire qui permet à la fois qui
permettent à la fois aux jeunes de
donner un temps nécessaire à leur pays
et qui permettent aussi de donner à ces
jeunes la transmission de repères de
valeurs ont parlé hier de la question de
la simulation
on parlait hier de la question de
l'identité pour des jeunes qui sont
devenus français qu'ils aient ce moment
où on leur transmet des repères des
valeurs me paraît là aussi nécessaire et
je note pour le rappeler que nous avions
lorsque nicolas sarkozy était président
de la république fait voter une loi qui
introduisait un service citoyen
obligatoire pour les mineurs délinquants
j'avais eu l'honneur de porter cette
proposition de loi
devenu loi à l'assemblée nationale elle
a été abrogée par madame taubira
mais ce temps là aussi pour ceux qui ont
besoin de retrouver une bonne direction
là où ils ont dérapé
parent est également essentiel